[Music]
good morning John Amsterdam is very good
I want to have a lot of different
thoughts from this place thoughts about
tulips and financialization and economic
bubbles and genetics thoughts about how
some clogs seemed quite big
until I saw others and then this Wow
thoughts about how there's a freaking
fair in the middle of this town right
now sharing space with 400 500 year old
buildings and fair food is pretty much
the same everywhere I asked for American
sauce because I figured it would be
ranch dressing but it's not I do not
know this flavor but of all the thoughts
I could have from this place guess what
I spotted it while casually Google
mapping around to see what there was to
do Oh a bench The Fault in Our Stars
bench on Google Maps with 75 reviews and
an average rating of 4.3 which is just
as good as the van Gogh Museum John I
assume that you are equally as
fascinated to find out what people say
when they review a bench which is why
this video is going to be mostly
people's reviews of the tiffy OS bench
it's just a bench it's a bench honestly
it's just an ordinary bench though
apparently that was worth four stars
it's bench that's it some don't even
think that it's a particularly good
bench millena in a two star review says
it's extremely uncomfortable and she
doesn't know how hazel and Gus did it
and dominica remarks on the benches
aesthetics I think more than its
cleanliness when she says that people
need to treat it better it does appear
to be the opposite of the hardest ball
of paint in that many tourists seem to
remove paint every time that go rather
than add it but of course there are lots
of great reviews of the bench Marciano
says that there are a few promise locks
which has apparently multiplied
substantially in the last eight months
because this is more than a few
Maharlika says that it was really fun to
try to recreate the famous movie poster
and suggest that you take a picture from
the other side of the canal which is how
they did in the movie that is an
excellent tip Caterina deeply disagrees
with all those remarking on the benches
lack of comfort saying 10 out of 10
would sit again Joanna agrees
saying best free attraction in Amsterdam
visited twice in one day
five stars though to be fair there are
no other free attractions in Amsterdam
now none of these reviews really
encapsulated my experience of the bench
so John I left my own review here it is
my brother wrote a book that made a
bench famous enough that it has 75 now
76 reviews on Google that's really weird
and also amazing if you're just
wandering around Amsterdam there's a
pretty good chance that you are going to
accidentally come across this bench it's
a fine bench but ultimately it's just a
bench that is in no way special except
because of what people bring to it I
guess that's like most important things
and also people we aren't much unless
you know our story I sat by this bench
for a long time watching people come up
and take pictures with the bench some of
them didn't seem to care that much and
we're just looking for something to do
between events but others were clearly
excited to interact a bit with a
physical space that was important to
them or to their relationships there
were a lot of friend groups and a lot of
couples it made me happy my brother is a
little bit obsessed with roadside
attractions in America and it is very
cool and very weird that he
unintentionally inspired a canalside
attraction across an ocean each person
brings to this thing their own stories
and their own connections each person
makes it a little bit more than it was
ever meant to be again maybe a little
bit like all of us John I'll see you on
Tuesday
[Music]
[Applause]